hi my name is Professor Tom W Bell I'm
professor Chapman Law School I'm here
today to talk to you about startup
cities it's a development I think that
libertarians will find really
interesting so let's get started with
just a preview of what I'm going to be
covering today we're going to start out
with two easy questions and then one
hard question and we'll talk about how
the Hondurans have tried to solve this
hard question and then I'll wrap up with
some theoretical discussion about how
you might create a startup city now let
me just clarify that I've had some
clients that work in this area I'm now
legally consulting with a client that's
active in Honduras and I'm speaking only
for myself not for my client anything
here today is purely academic let's talk
about first though some terminology not
everyone has heard this term startup
cities and I was introduced to the term
by these fine people at the startup
cities Institute at University Francisco
marroquín and Guatemala and they have
adopted this for good reasons I think
let me share with you some of the
alternative terms you might have heard
that i don't think fit quite as well
charter cities were introduced by Paul
Romer he's a brilliant economist and
they're kind of his baby really he has
something different in mind than the
people in Honduras and other folks who
talk about startup cities and Paul
roamers model basically an outside
country would go to a developing country
and offer it the same government
government that it has back home so the
Canadians for example would go down to
Honduras and run a city for them well
that's not exactly colonialism or even
neo colonialism but it's a little too
colonial for people in Honduras so I'm
gonna leave that term for Paul Romer and
his crew and wish them luck
what about Free Cities a lot of people
like that that's a need what they what
they started out with here first at
reason one problem with that is it's
associated with the free city of Danzig
a long story not a happy one it was a
territory between Poland and Germany
that basically the Nazis took over a lot
of people to here free city they think
the free city of Danzig now Gdansk
Poland and at any rate it's not really
an apt term because the cities were talk
about our only freer they're not
completely free they're not sovereigns
they're not like Athenian city-states so
again great term don't think it fits
best for what we have going on here
the Hondurans like model cities by
ciudades mondello's and that's great for
what they plan I'm going to tell you
more about what they're doing in
Honduras shortly but let's just set that
aside model cities for the Hondurans and
with startup cities we're talking about
a more general phenomenon I'll tell you
more about what start of cities are in a
minute and we'll get to it through these
questions let's talk about the
difference between where you live and
the government you have can I ask you an
easy question so do you like where you
live I know many of you live in LA it's
got beautiful weather
your family's there your job your
friends almost everybody likes where
they live if they don't they up and move
as easy question how about this one now
granted I'm a treason I think I know how
you're gonna answer this I just live in
LA myself and I got out
despite the regrets so those are easy
questions but here's the hard question
why can't you have better government
delivered to you wouldn't that be great
I know some people will say well you can
do that you just need to get politically
active you need to vote okay that is a
solution it's not a great solution we've
tried that I mean I vote and I have
pretty good local government but I voted
California federal levels and look what
that's gotten us by the way I'm not to
blame for any of that I just want to
clarify so let's talk about the
Hondurans now so they have this issue
too I'm sure Hondurans allow their
countries a beautiful country it's got
wonderful natural treasures a rich
culture but they've got some problems
here I put this screenshot of this video
up here so you can look it up if you
like the powerpoints available online if
you want to see it I recommend that you
look at this but that's not really going
to talk about that's just an example of
a Honduran person having alas typically
Honduran problems these are some
problems that the Hondurans are facing
these days this is a reason why they
want to bring good government better
government to their country I'm sure
they'd love to stay in Honduras but many
of them are leaving for reasons like
this they have the highest per-capita
murder rate in the world these days and
the next contender I just looked at this
is only around 60 people for every
hundred thousand people it's a drug war
my friends that's the problem really
it's a US export one
the nastiest and it's hitting the
Hondurans where they live as a
consequence Hondurans are leaving so
people born Honduras 9% of people born
Honduras have at last count and know
most of these people are undocumented so
this is probably an undercount 9% of
them are in the United States I know
that people still stuck in Honduras not
everybody can leave 30 percent of them
say they'd like to move to the United
States now this has created created a
crisis at the border Honduras has opened
up sort of a diplomatic diplomatic
outpost near the Texas border because
600 people a day a week they are
shipping back to Honduras
well the Hondurans you know they'd like
to have better government where they
live and they've tried it and their
answer to these problems are the Zed's
that's the Spanish acronym for zones of
economic development and employment
another reason the Hondurans are leaving
their home country is because they can't
find jobs so they want to bring the jobs
to Honduras that's 100 and flag and I
want to walk through with you this
really interesting legislation they've
passed it's very innovative it's
uniquely Honduras that's another reason
not to call these charter cities that's
Paul roamers baby what he has in mind is
not what the Hondurans have in mind I'm
very impressed with what they've done
here it's very creative very bold it's
by Hondurans it's for Hondurans and it's
under Honduran control they do not want
even Canadians much less Americans
coming in and telling them how to run
their country they want to do it
themselves I respect that I wish them
luck let's talk a little bit about how
they plan to do it there's a long
history of what Honduras has tried in
this area and I've been riding columns
in the Fremen a fine publication by fee
and you can look those up to find out
more I'm not going to go through the
history of their various legislations
and litigations they've been through
here we're just going to start with the
legislation they passed about a month
ago this is a map shows you where
Honduras is in case you forgot I know
it's not foremost in most of your minds
let's talk about what they've done in
this new legislation they amended their
constitution and they passed this
legislation and here are some things I'm
going to walk through this quickly we
can talk more in the Q&A if you like I'm
gonna walk through quickly some of the
things in this really interesting law
they've passed so the zed are part of
honduras but there are
of acidities they've said expressly you
want to create something like Hong Kong
in Honduras they set their own budgets
these EDS
they have to be balanced they set their
own taxes the statute caps the taxes at
a certain low level and they have to you
wonder what's in it for the Hondurans
well they want to create jobs they want
to basically try out some new modes of
governance but they also hope that these
ads are going to generate a lot of tax
revenues and that'll help fund the
Honduran government the said are not
I've heard people say they're like
privately-owned cities and there's gonna
be like a mr. burns cackling somewhere
and rubbing his fingers together that's
nuts the statute expressly says they
have to respect human rights they have
to provide all these benefits to the
people of Honduras again it's by the
Hondurans for the Hondurans let's talk a
little bit about the legal system this
is a picture of the hunter and Supreme
Court that building there on the Left
very attractive in some parts of
Honduras very nice
some parts otherwise very interesting
what they've done here it's a civil law
system like of course most Latin
American countries but in the Zed they
so admire the way the ha of the common
law has worked in England America and
Hong Kong they have said in the statute
we want you to adopt the common law for
the Zed the Zed can choose their own
civil laws they get to choose their own
contract law their own tort law their
own laws of property they have to
respect certain human rights but
basically the Zed are allowed to do that
with criminal laws it's a little
different criminal laws embody certain
values that are very important to the
Hondurans they do not want a new
Amsterdam not the New York kind of New
Amsterdam but they do not want a place
that has you know people selling to open
the streets and prostitution and
gambling although actually prostitution
gaming or legal Islanders but the point
is they say we have values under
criminal laws you have to keep our
criminal laws in these heads unless you
pass new laws and we approve them again
showing you the Hondurans are in control
the zed however control their own police
this is very important to investors and
residents of these new territories or
will be when and if they build them
because 100 police let's say they they
hope to learn from first world policing
standards it's another reason they hope
to bring these add to
country they want their civil servants
to learn from the best in the world
where will the zed be this is a nice
little topographic map of Honduras you
can see how mountain it is they're
mountainous it is they're not building a
Panama Canal across this anytime soon
and if you look at this closer you'll
see there's dark lines little dark lines
that designate the department's next to
the coast keep that in mind
where will this ed be the Congress has
to decree where the Zed will be and
they've not done that yet so no one can
really say for sure except they have
specified that low population density
areas near the coasts are already sort
of pre-approved for the Zed we still
don't know where those regions are
there's an administrative body in the
Honduran government that has to do a
survey and make a report we still don't
know it's very early this that's the
legislation passed just last month high
population areas might want to forms
Ed's also they need to hold referenda so
now when shoving us down the throats of
the Honduran people they have to vote
this into place if you're in a town or
city if it's in a low population area
there because there are large tracts of
land in Honduras that are privately
owned most notably by banana plantations
there the landowners have to opt in opt
in again no one's forcing this on the
Honduras they're choosing it themselves
let's talk about the way the Zed are
governed this is a picture of the
signing of the legislation I was
watching it online it was very exciting
I mean people think Honduras has some
kind of you know terrible government and
I won't portrayed as the best in the
world but look they they passed this
legislation twice the ax men of the
Constitution there was a lot of debate
in the Congress and still it passed by
an overwhelming margin so they were
doing what politicians everywhere do
they're thinking about their people
doing the best they can we should ask as
much as our part of our politicians the
President appoints 21 members of this
committee for the adoption of best
practices it's a little bit like the
legislature it's really more like a
board of trustees of the zet Congress
approves them this committee for the
adoption of best practices appoints the
technical secretary and the people where
the Zed's will be formed have some say
on who that person will be has to be a
person of Honduran citizenship by the
way and
the tango secretary is not quite just an
executive because the tankless secretary
can also pass laws and then this
technical secretary this is the
interesting thing for people who want to
help the Hondurans in their project the
technical secretary can contract with
outsiders for profit nonprofit
government advisers whoever can help to
provide services in the zet so that's a
quick look at what they're doing in
Honduras I'm sure you have a lot of
questions about this I have a lot of
questions about this and you know we're
working it out now and we hope we'll get
it all figured out I want to turn to a
different topic now so you you see now
the potential here it's a chance for
people who care about good government
from the private sector to help the
Hondurans bring good government to their
people I think we have a lot to offer
them and the Hondurans like bringing in
the private sector because why a couple
of reasons one it's not another flag on
your soil these are people under your
thumb you're hiring them to help you you
don't have to worry about well no one
worries about the Canadians but you
don't have to worry about Americans or
maybe you do worry about Canadians the
Hondurans have been burned by
colonialism they have reason to be
concerned
so you not to worry about somebody else
buying a flag on your soil and to the
Hondurans want to develop an industry
they're ahead of everybody else here if
the Hondurans figure this out they're
going to have locally grown experts in
governing services who can go to other
countries and advise them the parties
with whom I've been consulting have been
talking of course with the Hondurans but
also other countries this is perhaps
we're at the cusp of a new industry and
the Hondurans are right there at the
front of it I hope it brings a lot of
prosperity to their people but let's
turn to theory now okay I'm an academic
primarily and I've given this a lot of
thought over the years I've written
about polycentric laws it's called
I want to share with you some thoughts
about how maybe perhaps one might help
ponderings and other countries create
these model cities charter cities what
do you recall I'm I prefer startup
cities this is a screenshot from future
cities development Inc that was the
first company I worked with it was
headed by CEO Patri Friedman and this
was back before the first time this is
the first time the Hondurans took a
whack at this problem and their supreme
court found it unconstitutional and FCD
out of respect for the commitments it
made to their investors had to fold up
but it was great working with Patri he
was right there on the cutting edge and
and I put this up to him
mind you and really myself you know
don't hyperventilate and get too excited
about this because probably nothing will
happen that's what happened last time I
rented a lot of libertarian fan boys and
girls and they get all excited and I
tell him you know my heart was broken
once I try not to get too excited this
is all this theory folks all this theory
let's not take it too seriously so let's
talk about how you might do some of
these things in in theory I'm going to
offer you a few headings here first of
all I'm going to describe a way to
structure a city so that it's both
cooperative residential association and
at the same time a for-profit
corporations it's kind of a new model I
think it's interesting to think about in
theory maybe it'll work in practice I'm
going to talk about plug-and-play
government how that would work it's a
quick and easy way to build an entire
city basically from scratch without a
lot of civil servants who have tenure
I'll talk about the spatial basic
judicial building block and lastly
corrective democracy there will be
democracy in the startup cities of some
form this is one way to implement it
that I think is especially protective of
private rights and individual liberty
let's start with this first time this is
actually this was the same shot I had in
my opening screen this is actually a
privately owned community this is the
largest cooperative residential
Association in the world it's in the
Bronx of New York City
it's called co-op city about 55,000
people live there and those high-rises
it's got some very interesting features
let's talk about how coops work and why
they're appealing to people who like
property rights a corporation owns all
the property in a co-op and they lease
it to the residents but who owns the who
owns the corporation the residents own
it so the people who live in the coop
own shares of the corporation from which
they lease the property so it's a
combination of kind of a corporation and
a co-op and these as I've noted get very
large fifty five thousand people in
co-op city there are schools shops
churches offices parks everything you
could want right there on site and for a
start-up cities a very attractive model
but you need to tweak it a little why
startup cities or you know could be
built basically on you know
open fields you need a lot of
infrastructure and investors investors
might not be comfortable handing over
the keys to people who live there alone
they might want a share of the
corporation too so you need to make the
shareholders more diverse so investors
can also be shareholders and the use of
a corporate structure allows you to do
very interesting innovative things with
the vesting of shares for example you
could set it up so that every year that
you live in this residential cooperative
you get another vote so that old-timers
have more say in the management of the
city there are other things I could talk
about here I just want to point out that
once you start viewing the city as like
a corporation with shares you can start
distributing equity in ways that aligns
the incentives of the people that live
and work there with the city itself and
everybody benefits let's talk a little
bit about oh let me show you some more
pictures this is co-op city from the
side you can see this is a real big deal
lot of capital assets there I'll show
you another one from Letchworth England
this too is another kind of cooperative
residential community but this one is
more in the line of a pastoral English
community that's their entrance to their
city streets houses very nice houses
there it's kind of an upper middle class
community I should know by the way co-op
city in the Bronx solidly middle-class
solid the middle class it's not just for
rich people another picture from alleged
worth that's their downtown area let's
talk about now a way to build a city
from scratch and I learned about this or
my friend Paul fine and this reason TV
video he created called Sandy Springs
Georgia the city that outsourced
everything brilliant what they did there
this is a Olive reporter and he was a
retired engineer they wanted to create
this new municipality in a kind of an
excerpt of Atlanta and needed it they
needed to do it fast and cheap and
Oliver Porter figured out how to do it
he's very lean municipal government just
a few employees and they contract out
everything they put a request for bids
up they brought in people to fix the
streets to run the parks to collect the
garbage they contracted with other
cities to provide fire and police and so
it allows them to run the city and a
lean and mean mean in the sense of
cheap not vicious and the lean and mean
way I was very impressed by that and I
think we can we can even take that model
farther you can even outsource law
remember the Hondurans in there Zed said
we want common law who are you gonna get
the common law they don't have it
locally what you could use Randy Barnett
suggested this in one of his books is
use the restatements of law in the
restatements of law academics judges and
lawyers have surveyed the decisions in
the common law system and kind of summed
them up in a statutory form so it'd be
very easy for a z city starting from
scratch to simply take those
restatements off the shelf and say
there's your law we don't have to create
a legislature we don't even need to
create judges someone has done the work
for us plug and play in both city
services and even in the law I want to
tell you about this little model I've
been playing with now I'm kind of
excited about this because it uses Legos
I got one of my pocket here my son let
me use this for my ax for my talk let me
tell you how this would work now this is
a basic building block of justice I'm
going to illustrate it here with some
Lego blocks
imagine that these two little Lego box
these two Lego blocks represent a
plaintiff and defendant they get in a
fight maybe they're in a Z and they're
getting a fight over maybe some contract
one of them says you shorted me they're
not enough bricks on this pallet in the
other one says you're wrong there are
through their choice of law and choice
of forum clause and their agreement
they've already settled on how to
resolve the dispute and here's how they
might do it the two parties pick
arbitrators this is a method I got from
triple-a the American Arbitration
Association they're not the only people
who use this method but they're they use
it very widely so the defendant picks
one arbitrator and the plaintiff picks
another arbitrator and those arbitrators
pick a third arbitrator which creates
our panel I put them up on a little Lego
block there which creates our panel of
arbitrators now what's the beauty of
this we don't even have a standing
judiciary we don't need a standing
judiciary for this you cobble together
the panel from the choices of the
disputants and they can't deny that's a
fair panel each of them gets to pick an
arbitrator the two arbitrators who are
removed from the dispute and who take
oaths by the way to resolve the dispute
fairly and partially pick the third
arbitrator so that's the first
in this little building block of justice
and you can see there I've kind of
merged so we got the first element let's
talk about the next element
what can the arbitrators do in
traditional arbitration the arbitrator's
frequently split the baby what they do
is one party says I owe you nothing the
other says you owe me a million and the
arbitrator's end up around five hundred
thousand dollars in baseball arbitration
as it's sometimes called I like to call
it ball the arbitration after Baldy
Harper's anybody heard of Baldy Harper
he was a founder of the Institute for
Humane studies and I first learned about
this method of setting remedies and
arbitration from something Baldy Harper
wrote in ball the remedies arbitration
the arbitrator's have to choose a remedy
offered by one of the parties
none of this split and the baby stuff
the problem with the splitting the baby
approach is you aim for extremes that
does not encourage the parties to settle
the dispute with this kind of choosing
the remedy the parties realize oh if I
aim for the moon they probably won't
choose my remedy I need to be realistic
in fact you go through three rounds of
this in baseball arbitration first the
parties start out here and then they
look at their offers and demands and
they get closer and closer to the middle
it encourages peace and the last element
is loser pays very common everywhere
except the United States also encourages
settlement of disputes so the result is
you combine those three things you have
a little building block every dispute
can go to this little kind of neat
little block and the that simple unit
can be can be combined with other
elements to combine to create a whole
city you use this plug and play
government this is one of the blocks
everything bound together by consent
people agreeing to live together under
these rules and that very simple
judicial process I think you'll find it
will encourage parties never even
actually end up with their litigation it
encourages peace encourages peace
reaching agreement before they even
litigate a few more things here
corrected democracy I wrote about this
in the Freeman basically the idea here
is democracy can be okay I often hear
Friends of Liberty classical liberals
libertarians say bad things about
democracy and I understand why because
of one problem with democracy if you
give the keys to the masses they drive
the government into a ditch the problem
is democracy is not very good at
building programs but it is good
at getting rid of things with a
corrective democracy the people only
vote against particularly are able to
say it's like whipping your hand from
the stove when it's too hot the people
say oh we don't like that law get rid of
it doesn't tell us what to put in its
place maybe we put nothing in its place
think about farm programs if we
subjected farm programs the United
States so this kind of corrective
democracy do you think they'd still be
around no there's not that many farmers
we get rid of it I think of all the
programs we get rid of all the bad laws
corrective democracy works to prune away
bad laws we have other processes to put
into place people who will create new
good laws if we need new laws maybe we
don't so to wrap this up I want to say
the important thing about startup cities
is as their name suggests their
experiments and consent it's a way to
let people try to bring more competition
to governing services lowering the costs
of choosing governments bringing good
government to people so they don't have
to up and go - it'd be great for the
Hondurans great for people in other
countries ultimately great for people
United States one reason I'm very
excited about this is because I love my
country
and I want it I want to exercise some
tough love here and save the United
States step up your game I want to see
some competition for all the bad
government I see in the United States
they're getting away with murder now
literally I think they need to see more
competition this is a way to bring it
and of course 100 ads are this very bold
very interesting very innovative very
new we don't know how to workout program
to help some of the worst off people in
the world with perhaps the best hope for
liberty and theory suggests but hardly
mandates some of the features I've
described this is just an egghead
talking really what we need to do is
have lots of people take a crack at
these hard problems of governance I
certainly don't have all the answers I'm
not sure anybody does and in the
abstract nobody knows what will work
what we need are lots of experiments and
consent then maybe we'll find a better
way for people who live together in
peace and prosperity and freedom